- On this week to celebrate
our season three premier,
we've been asking some L.A. celebrities
to share their L.A. Top Three.
(upbeat music)
♪ L.A. Top Three ♪
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- These are personalized
picks from our friends
who have lived here for years.
Not your usual L.A. spots that you'll find
on an internet search.
Today's Top Three comes from
one of the funniest guys ever,
let's head out to the field
where meteorologist...
I don't get to say that word a lot,
and I like the word meteorologist,
I don't know why.
(audience laughs)
Meteorologist. Melissa McGee from our...
Meteorologist Melissa McGee.
Come on, all the M's.
(audience cheers)
From our partner station,
NBC for Los Angeles,
she's standing by.
What's up, Melissa?
(Kelly laughs)
- Hey, Kelly! It's so
nice to see you again!
- It's nice to see you, too!
You were destined for it.
Meteorologist Melissa
McGee, it was all destiny.
- A lot of M's, yes.
- Yes.
I like it, I like it.
Will you introduce us to
the secret celebrity curator
of today's L.A. Top Three list?
- Yes, absolutely.
And you know, we're in
gorgeous, sunny Santa Monica
and I'm gonna reveal to you
where we are in just a moment,
but I do wanna tell you first,
that we've got a marine layer
that's starting to burn on off.
That sun is coming out, people are happy,
and the forecast calls
for a delicious lunch.
And to tell you more about that,
(Kelly yells)
I've got the one, the only,
here he is, the man himself,
(audience cheers)
Arsenio Hall!
- [Kelly] Let's go, Arsenio!
- Let's get it. Elbows bump.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- I always do this.
(Kelly cheers and laughs)
- Our favorite meteorologist, Melissa.
(audience cheers)
Yes.
- [Melissa] Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- My whole audience is doing it, man.
You left an impact.
- [Arsenio] Oh, that's so...
(Arsenio laughs)
- Arsenio, I know how much you love L.A.
So, how long have you lived here?
- I've been here too long!
You know how old I am!
I came here from Cleveland in 19...
(Arsenio mumbles)
(Kelly and audience laugh)
But I'm here now, and I got my
three secret places for you.
- Okay,
(audience applauds)
well, we're talking about best spots
for a leisurely lunch today,
so what are Arsenio Hall's
top three secret leisurely
lunches in Los Angeles?
Start with number three.
- Okay, number three.
I accidentally promised my girlfriend
that I wouldn't eat meat
until the pandemic was over.
(Kelly laughs)
That was a mistake.
A huge mistake, but it
lead me to great places.
I found a wonderful vegan restaurant,
my little hideout downtown,
and it's called Âu Lac, okay?
And it's vegetarian,
and I love the chef there.
His name is Chef Ito.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
- Chef Ito made a vow to
silence many, many years ago,
and it he doesn't speak.
So if you go there, he's not dissing you,
he just doesn't speak.
He can speak, but he doesn't.
- What?
- [Arsenio] He makes
incredible vegan stuff.
Yeah, well, see. You and I love to talk,
and you'd love this chef,
because I talk to him,
and he don't say nothing back.
- [Kelly] He'd listen.
- And I dominate the conversation.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
(audience applauds)
- That's my kind of date.
(Kelly laughs)
All right, wait. What's number two?
- Number two, sometimes
if you drive down PCH,
way, way, way, way down PCH,
(kelly giggles)
there's a place called Spruzzo.
A wonderful Italian place.
They have great food,
but I rarely get to the
food 'cause I like bread.
They have the best bread, Kelly!
And I just eat bread for like
a hour and have cocktails.
(audience applauds)
You can see the beach.
It's an incredible place. Try Spruzzo's.
- I want that pizza!
- And here we are at my number
one secret lunch location,
El Cholo, Clarkson!
(audience cheers)
Yeah, baby!
It's near Wilshire at 11th,
but you have to enter on 11th
on the side.
- [Kelly] Mm.
- [Arsenio] Kinda off the beaten path,
another one of my secret locations.
This is my favorite dish.
It's a crab meat enchilada.
- [Kelly] Yes!
(audience exclaims)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Arsenio] They also make
my favorite margarita.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Arsenio] And it's a
Cadillac Margarita with heat!
- [Kelly] Yes!
(audience applauds)
- [Arsenio] So they put jalapeños in it.
- Oh my God.
- [Arsenio] And it gets you there, Kelly.
If you ever sit with writers
and wanna write jokes,
this is the fluid that
will make you funny.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
(audience applauds)
- [Arsenio] Me and Owen
Smith, all the guys come here,
and it's crazy. Anyway,
Melissa, come on in.
- Yes, I'm dying!
- Our favorite meteorologist.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- She says there's a track of warm air
coming from the north, y'all.
(Melissa laughs)
So, get ready for it.
- Dying to try it.
- [Kelly] I don't mind the gloomy.
- [Arsenio] You gotta try it.
- I don't mind the gloomy, it's good.
That meal looks amazing
and I can't stand y'all right
now 'cause I'm not there.
But it is always good to
see you Arsenio and Melissa.
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much!